اعلنت مجموعه من جنود الاحتياط في وحدات
النخبه العسكريه والاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه في بيان لهم انهم لن يشاركوا
في بعض الواجبات المكلفين بها اعتبارا من
اليوم الاحد وذلك مع التصاعد حده
الاحتجاجات ضد خطه تغيير النظام القضائي
الذي تخطط له الحكومه وقال 450 متظاهرا من
جنود الاحتياط المتطوعين و200 اخرون
متطوعون وجنود احتياط من جهاز المخابرات
الموساد انهم يرفضون لاستدعاءات واداء اي
واجب
هذا وطالب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو مكتب المدعي العام والسلطات
المختصه بالتصرف بشكل حاسم ضد من يحرض على
قتله وعائلته والوزراء واعضاء الكنيسه
مشيرا الى ضروره وجود مناقشه موضوعيه
للاصلاح القانوني
لن نقبل الفوضى ومطالبه البعض بقطع الطرق
ومنظر الدماء في الشوارع وايضا تعرض
الشخصيات العامه للاذى لن نقبل بالعنف من
اي جانب اتوقع من قاده الشرطه تطبيق
القانون لمنع العنف وعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها وان يتصرف مكتب المدعي العام بشكل
حاسم ضد الذين يحرضون على قتل الوزراء
واعضاء الكنيست وقتل رئيس الوزراء وعائلته
فالدوله التي تريد الحياه لا تستطيع ان
تتحمل مثل هذه الظواهر ولن نتحملها يجب ان
تكون هناك مناقشه حقيقيه وموضوعيه وعادله
للاصلاح القانوني
الى القدس ومزيد من المتابعه مع مراسل
العربيه زياد حلب زياد اهلا وسهلا بك هل
ما يجري داخل قوات الاحتياط زياد يمكن
وصفه بدون مبالغه بالتمرد على الاوامر ام
لا لا يجب تكبير الحجر وتكبير المساله
اكثر مما يجب
هذا قد يصل طالب الى هذا الحد في وقت قريب
الخشيه الاساسيه في اسرائيل بان هذه الكره
الثلج بدات
باليوم بعمليا عصيان عسكري من قبل المئات
وليس مجرد جنود احتياط عاديين هؤلاء من
وحدات خاصه يصعب تعويضهم في الجيش
الاسرائيلي عاده المهام الموكله اليهم هي
خلف الحدود بالاضافه الى طيارين وملاحي جو
ايضا يتطوعون في احتياط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي بهذا المعنى هذا يبدا الان
كمؤشر
بمقاطعه التدريبات ولكن بدون ان شك لا
يمكن التقليل في اسرائيل من خطوره هذا
الموضوع وفق مراقبين بان الامر قد يتحول
الى كره ثلج وقد يؤثر على معنويات وعلى
اداء الجيش الاسرائيلي من حيث المعنويات
والقدره القتاليه حتى هنا السؤال يعني منذ
ان بدات الازمه زياد وانت يعني خير من
تابع هذه الازمه قيل انه الازمه هي ازمه
سياسيه لن تتوسع لتصل الى الاجهزه الامنيه
والجيش ولكن الان الا يجوز السؤال ان
التشرذم
والازمه بدات تتسلل وبقوه الى الاجهزه
الامنيه والقوات الاسرائيليه وحتى جهاز
المساب
هذا صحيح جدا ولهذا يدق خبراء كثيرون في
اسرائيل ناقوس الخطر ويقولون بان الامر لم
يعد في اطار التحذير من ان تصل الامور الى
ضرب وحده الجيش الاسرائيلي ومعنويات هذا
الجيش بالفعل هي وصلت الى صفوف الجيش
للتذكير فقط قوات الاحتياط هي عماد الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الواقع ثلاثه ارباع هذا
الجيش ليس من القوات النظاميه وانما من
قوات الاحتياط مثلا سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
نحو 50% من الطيارين هم من الاحتياط حتى
ممن يشاركون في الغارات التي تسمع عنها
بين الحين والاخر في سوريا يلفظها ايضا
جنود احتياط او طياره احتياط وبهذا المعنى
الامور وصلت فعليا الى الجيش لهذا هناك
دعوات لتجميد هذه الخطه من قبل الحكومه
المشكله هي بان الاحتجاجات تسير
واصرار الحكومه على ما يسمى بالانقلاب على
نظام القضاء يسير بقوه هو الاخر زياد
عندما تقرا المحللين في الصحف الاسرائيليه
يعني ترى مصطلحات جديده جدا لم تكن
مستخدمه يعني لاول مره في تاريخها تواجه
اسرائيل خطرا وجوديا يعني مصطلح الخطر
الوجودي وانه اذا لم يتم حل هذه المساله
سريعا فان الحرب الاهليه اتيه لمحاله هل
هذه مبالغات ام لا هذا واقع الحال
عندما يقول وزير دفاع سابق مثل بيني جان
ساده الامر يحذر من حرب اخرى بات يسميها
بدلا من حرب اهليه
وكذا ايضا الكثير من الخبراء وعندما يقول
يعني مدير وكاله الطاقه الذريه
الاسرائيليه السابق الذي انهى مهام منصبه
قبل فتره وجيزه عندما يقول بان الخطر لم
نعد بحاجه لايران لتهديد وجودنا لان الخطر
الداهم هو ما يحدث في داخل اسرائيل ولهذا
لا يمكن ان يعتبر الامر في هذا السياق
مبالغه لان الامور ذاهبه الى هذا المكان
الى يعني ان يتطور العنف الجزئي الذي نراه
في بين الحين والاخر في المظاهرات ان
يتطور الموضوع الى محاوله حسم في الشارع
هناك محاوله حسب في مكانين منفردين في
البرلمان حيث الاغلبيه لصالح نتنياهو وفي
الشارع والمشكله لبنيامين نتنياهو وحكومه
اليمين بانه لا حديث الان عن يسار ويمين
يعني هذا تسطيح للحاله في اسرائيل وانما
هناك اغلبيه من اكثر من 60% في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ايضا في عداد اليمين
الاسرائيلي ضد هذه الخطه من حكومه من
القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا
لك دائما زياد على هذه المتابعه